foreign
what's the shtick what else could you
make a dating app for like what other
people are underrepresented that they
would need a dating app for them people
with specific pets I was thinking pets
in my head dating apps all right that
doesn't exist lizard people yeah geez
that doesn't exist these are real people
though no people that like have those
people that are homeless people
homeless people dating apps no it's uh
bombs for bombs you may not have a home
but you could find yourself you may not
have money but we have a business for
you well they have smartphones
homeless hookups it's definitely not
okay
um
worth a shot who needs who needs a match
come on
I feel like everyone can date so easily
now with multiple options that what blue
collect bugs collect bugs
those are freaking so it's like super
Niche it's pretty Niche but but you know
what
it makes a lot of sense people that want
to cheat on their spouse
that's regular how about uh jail in jail
jail people in jail they already got
that too really really
yeah they call them inmates.com
oh what if you want to be a cuck
oh that's already that's already on
FetLife what's it called what's that fat
life fat life why is it called fetish
um it's like if you have a thing like a
kink it matches your Kink with someone
else so it's like come bang my wife
please yeah oh wow
um that's a wild one that one is wild
because some people's it gets it gets
kind of dicey because some people's
thing is like take me by force yeah dude
that's
that's tough yeah it looks not so what
do you think it is it's not rich people
I I'm sure some of these people are rich
you have a clue yeah here's the thing
I'll just tell you because it's actually
really really smart
it is a dating app to match people who
believe in the same conspiracy theories
that's [__] hilarious relief
I don't know how if this was a joke but
I did remember seeing like an ad for um
it showed a guy and a girl with foil
hats that's it and it said like a
conspiracy it was like a conspiracy day
that's not a joke it's a real thing oh
really yeah they had foil hats right
like in the ad I not everyone believes
in the full hats the article in the
article explaining it the writer may
have used a stock image of that to
explain it but I've seen it not in the
app itself okay well on the episode
it'll take people that like let's say
like flat earthers can match with each
other wow they're the only ones that
could date each other even like 5G being
like destructive uh what about The
Reptilian ones The Reptilian ones I
think that might be part of it yeah
people who believe in Chemtrails
vaccination alien abominable snowman
yeah
I feel like MK Ultra girls are gonna be
hotter than Flat Earth Girls you don't
think Flat Earth girls are hot I don't
think so many flat Earth Girls I do a
lot of flowers
in my high school there's a lot of
flatters girls I feel like there was a
most of the flat earthers are all dudes
Flat Earth
yeah okay beards
have you seen the Flat Earth conventions
yeah mostly you know there's conspiracy
like
um
not groupies uh we're influencers
there's like conspiracy like girls that
are covering this whole genre where
they're like hot girls that cover
conspiracy news while they put makeup on
a trip I'll believe it oh really yeah
you seen that [__] I haven't seen the
makeup ones listen nowadays
so you put on makeup while you talk
about conspiracies it's a whole thing
it's the only way I've seen it
yeah that is a thing uh yeah the flat
earthers don't particularly look hot
who's the hottest group
um let me show you let's guess who's the
bustiest group probably the 5G the Jazz
Festival
is crazy right to think about it but I
think it'll get enough regular folks
okay fair you know it's it's like wide
enough where some people be like oh I
could see that happen I can trickle in
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but then again
I think you're always surprised with who
follows certain conspiracies was it
um Tila Tequila she went full-on
hardcore conspiracy theorists she went
like [__] she just went nuts totally
though oh Hollow Earth what's the hollow
Earth hollow Earth is like like so you
know how the Earth right now has like a
core and a mantle all that kind of [__]
no no no no no it's got like a sky and a
sun and like all this [__] inside the
earth inside of it and there's like
Giants and [__] and you could go you
could get through the Antarctica way
cooler than we got up here yeah there's
a hole in Antarctica you could go
through that's where the aliens are and
there's flying deers and all kinds of
cool [__] I think that just being a
dreamer I don't think that's really
concerned do you like the idea of a app
that is servicing conspiracy theories uh
yeah because I think it'll it'll
strengthen the conspiracy Theory I mean
oh yeah yeah because two people who
completely agree should get get together
and then hash it out right and then yeah
exactly thinkers that's what's gonna
happen yeah yeah that is kind of what
some people are saying is the um it
could lead to radicalization because
your own I think that's already there
dude yeah yeah you're talking about like
the Internet isn't like help enough I
think that word is a stretch now by the
way what radicalization everything's
radical now everything yeah yeah like
what are you posting some you're telling
something on social media and people
like that's radical it's like I'm just
saying on social media and then they'll
call you a narcissist because that's the
other overused word that everyone use
all the time yes and gaslighting maybe
the most overused word of the entire
2020s goes through for sure everyone's a
spectrum of narcissism though yeah
exactly not me
Steve's the least nah dude I was really
really popular in high school really
popular
there's a thing like uh that I read in
this article that was like one of the
categories was like people who believe
in vaccination shedding do you know
about that vaccination shedding I didn't
even know what that was what does that
mean it's people that believe that if
you've had the vaccine that you are
shedding off like certain uh I guess
like chemicals or things that
unvaccinated people do not want
um
legit yeah sounds like people that are
like you got AIDS I don't want your
sweat on me I want to hear their like
scientific reasoning behind there's none
of course there isn't no because they
they're thinking you know like uh people
who are like proudly unvaccinated to a
crazy degree and they just don't want to
be around they they believe that it's
kind of like an opposite thing where
they're like I'm so unvaccinated that I
do not want to be around vaccinated
people for fear of catching the vaccine
I bet all the JFK conspiracy ones are
old interesting do JFK conspiracy is
pretty tight though yeah but they're
probably like the old people those are
like the most sane people bro yeah
because that one's a trip don't they
think the mob did it yeah isn't that
well no the mob Jack Ruby did Kill
Oswald yeah but then it's like was that
was he doing that to cover it up right
was he part of it yeah it's a big thing
I think the mob did Bobby
because right after Jay uh John F
Kennedy the brother got shot from uh FBI
brother I bet you the mob was run by the
feds anyway yeah because during that
time right weren't they all like clicked
up no well I've never met Gods but then
sometimes some families were owned by
the feds because they just got got
because I thought the Kennedys were
weren't they involved with them yeah and
that's why they were mad because the mob
helped them get uh Power and then they
turned on them they actually cheated in
the election to help him win on like
that actually happened last time
technique stuffing ballot boxes like
hanging Chads dude no but not even like
they were just stuffing ballot boxes
like doing all kinds of shady [__] and
then Nixon was like yeah I'm gonna step
down because this is kind of [__]
wild and I don't want to put the country
through it yeah which is kind of like
Noble
and like but people don't really do that
anymore huh
why would they do yeah why would they
because they don't take the L so I think
it yeah I'll find someone who's a JFK
conspiracy theorist yeah they sound more
normal dude I would 100 think JK was
killed by the feds
and you can't convince me otherwise JFK
can't be normal and not radical
well they are it wasn't there a thing
where they blocked a Declassified file
they were doing it they're so innocent
everything's cool but it could be like
the CIA plus the mob like it could be so
many people just involved kind of like
the Epstein thing where like there's
just way too many powerful people
involved that they're just like this is
gonna make it look so bad we can't
release this what about Sasquatch is
that on there some scratch oh yeah I bet
Sasquatch people are cool I would love
to go to Sasquatch me too let's do it
one guy in the woods though dude I know
but it's like one yo what do you guys
think that skin walker stuff wait what's
that Skinwalker you guys don't know what
that is I know
so skinwalkers
who knows if they're real or not but um
you might you might be able to explain
it more but it's like this type of like
entity thing that can shape-shift people
say they've been coming in like content
battle killer thing right like remember
all the cow the cattle got killed their
blood sucked out no so they say it looks
like this there actually was a thing on
Netflix like Unsolved Mysteries like the
the what's the name Naomi something new
Navajo
maybe it's a Navajo thing yeah yeah
there were some Rangers that believed
they saw these and they couldn't whoa
what the [__] so apparently like that's
what its form is but it can like shift
into different
thing that looks like a gorilla
we just snake the whole time they got a
really big butt a lot of people are on
that one right now oh dang
um I was single and it was dark oh baby
yep I'll be making that Spirit Colleen
what kind of conspiracy theory would you
try to meet somebody like if you got to
pick one conspiracy yeah so even the
magic bullet theory that Oswald just
like you know got lucky and all this
[__] yeah what kind of conspiracy guy
would you be into yeah if you had to
pick one out of those options and you're
you're next and he's super hot it looks
like Dion Cole yeah he's Deon Cole but
he believes in this conspiracy like
what's gonna combine you together I
don't know I don't know you gotta pick
you gotta pick
um It's gotta be like aliens alien she's
an alien girl aliens aliens that's the
one that gives me hope yeah I might even
believe in that you know it seems
realistic not Sasquatch you believe in
aliens
let's see do you no no Sasquatch
Sasquatch you wouldn't believe in
Sasquatch so she's like I can't wait for
a guy to tell me that he's been Pro by
an alien
like that's his fetish he's awesome
he's like I got Pro by alien you know
yeah he gets a lot of hits on that app
from Aliens I think it's pretty cool
that uh at least you know whether you
believe in nothing or you believe in
these things it's nice that you have a
chance to be happy
[Laughter]
no there's no I'm not looking at people
on the app is